[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: OK.
Greetings, everyone.
Thank you for coming today.
I'll say a few things.
So in terms of the
calendar, and we're
finishing off this section
right before Thanksgiving break,
when I get--
excuse me, on
identification today.
We're on that momentarily.
Then, we have two
formal lectures
after the break, on
Tuesday, Thursday.
So that's the calendar.
Then, in terms of the
readings today, it's
important to point out, the
section on identification
and falsification
we're about to do,
there are three
starred readings,
and they all come from Varian,
and they're all really, really
good.
In fact, I had to abbreviate
in spots, in order
to cover all the topics.
So we are drawing on
this material in part,
and you will find it useful.
Again, it's not the whole book.
It's just Varian,
in these sections,
8.1 through 8.3, 8.5, and 8.7.
Then, from last time, let's have
a little bit of a discussion.
Let's see.
Daniel, can you
tell me, as best you
can, what the definition of
is the positive representative
consumer and the normative
representative consumer,
explaining what
they are Intuitively
AUDIENCE: So like
the idea is you're
trying to treat the entire
economy as a single person.
So a positive
representative consumer
is, at any given level
of wealth and input,
the way to maximize utility is
to spend your wealth the way
that customer would and
then distribute that
to the people like in some way.
We don't really know which
way from the consumer,
but like it'll just be
like the best distribution.
And then the normative
is very similar,
except for instead of
the utility maximizing,
it's the Pareto optimal way
to distribute the wealth.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Yeah.
I guess I would sharpen up a
little bit the positive one.
The idea is to get the excess
demand curve for the economy,
as if it were coming from
this representative consumer
maximizing utility subject
to resource constraints.
And then that
representative consumer
has all the resource constraints
in the entire economy.
In particular, the budget
just says, don't spend more
than the economy-wide wealth.
And you said that,
but maybe better
for me to repeat
it a little bit.
Yeah, and then the
normative one is a way
to rank order
allocations, according
to the Pareto principal.
But ironically,
rather than keeping
track of all the individuals,
and whether they're
made better off or worse
off, we can collapse it to
as if we were maximizing
utility for the whole economy
through the lens of this
representative consumer.
And as you said, that determines
the overall allocation.
It doesn't pin down the
potential reallocation
of wealth that is necessary,
if you go from something Pareto
inferior to something Pareto
superior or Pareto optimal,
you may have to
compensate the losers
and by taxing the winners.
OK, great.
So we made a lot of use
of this Gorman form.
Caleb, can you tell me in words,
what is this Gorman polar form?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So like it breaks
down the equilibrium
into like a linear form.
I guess, I don't know
exactly how to explain it.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Do you
remember any of the notation?
What is it breaking
down exactly?
AUDIENCE: Like the
equilibrium in the economy.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Does
the word indirect utility
come to mind?
OK.
It's the indirect
utility function,
which is the maximized
utility subject to the given
vector of prices and wealth.
And the statement about Gorman
form is this form in which
that that indirect
utility function
must take in order to do this
positive and normative thing.
Can someone volunteer to tell
me what, in words if you can,
what the green form looks like?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I can take this one.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Great.
AUDIENCE: So the Gorman form is
basically an indirect utility
function that is linear
in W, the overall wealth
of the economy.
So it's some function A,
which depends on prices,
plus sum function B, which
depends on prices, plus W.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Yeah.
That's exactly right.
Well, it's at the level
of the individuals.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: So if
we had an individual I,
where do we put the
I in that equation?
AUDIENCE: So it is
on both the wealth
that an individual
person faces, and I
think as well on the
functions A and B.
Each individual can have their
own specific form for that.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
Two out of three.
So it's on the wealth, because
at the individual level,
it's the indirect utility is
a function of the individual's
wealth, say W sub I. The
intercept term, the A of P
is the AI of P. So that's where
the heterogeneity is loaded.
But it's not on the B, and
maybe you can remember why.
What did we say about those
linear expansion paths?
AUDIENCE: Oh, those need to
be parallel linear expansion
paths, and so they need to be
identical for each consumer.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Exactly.
That's perfect.
So there's no I for the B part.
OK, and then finally--
oh, I almost answer
this already,
but we can discuss it some more.
How realistic are the necessary
and sufficient conditions
for Gorman aggregation,
based on what you've
learned in previous lectures?
In other words, do
you believe it or not?
Guanpeng?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I believe one of the
necessary conditions
was that the aggregate
demand doesn't
depend on the distribution
of the wealth.
It has to depend only
on the total wealth.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
That's true, and then what
does that imply
about the underlying
households in the economy?
AUDIENCE: I believe it
implies some uniformity.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Yeah.
It's uniform in
the way that wealth
impacts marginal changes.
AUDIENCE: Right.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: So yeah.
Those linear expansion
paths are a shorthand way
of saying different
people can consume
different amounts, because
they have different wealth.
But if you start changing
wealth distribution,
by definition, holding the
aggregate fixed, if you're
going to change
the distribution,
you're increasing wealth
for some households
and decreasing it for others.
And those marginal changes--
and not just local
changes, global changes--
these could be big
redistributions, offset
each other in the aggregate.
The amount that
consumption of a given good
is going down for the
people who are taxed
is exactly equal to the amount
that consumption of that good
is going up for the people
who get the subsidies.
And that's why the
redistribution doesn't
matter for the aggregate.
That's why we can do this
representative consumer
thing to get the
aggregates, because only
aggregate wealth matters for
aggregate demand, as you said.
However, it matters a whole
lot for the individuals.
I mean if you're
paying taxes, lump
sum to the government for it to
be redistributed, you get hurt.
So it's not a welfare statement.
And I'll just
repeat, that's why,
depending on what we're doing
with free trade or something
else, in principle, we may
be able to make everyone
better off, as we are
told by situations
where there is a representative
in indifference curve
and we're using
implicitly Gorman's form
for the indirect utilities.
But that doesn't mean
everyone is actually
better off without
the intervention,
because the factor
prices are moving,
and some people own more labor
than capital and vice versa.
So we really do need to be
actively redistributing wealth
in order to reap the
gains for everyone
to benefit from
the gains to trade.
OK.
So this lecture from
18 was about a tool,
namely Gorman
aggregation, which you
saw in the form of
the earlier lectures
without me elaborating on it.
So this was an opportunity
to do that, but it
does take underlying
assumptions,
and in part, the microdata
seem to contradict.
Yeah.
I didn't push you
guys very hard,
but do you believe it or not?
Then, it's do we see these
differentiable wealth effects
in practice?
We have normal goods, necessary
goods, and so on and even given
goods, as I said.
To know if it's a
bad approximation,
we'd have to take a
stand on the underlying
non-Gorman indirect
utility functions
and simulate the economy, and
see if it looks almost linear,
even though it's not.
In which case, the
redistribution might be small.
Sorry.
I said that wrong.
The literal form of
Gorman aggregation
as an analytic
technique might get
us close to what we
want as a benchmark,
and since it's so tractable,
it's very tempting to use it.
But then again, for
other utility functions,
we could be really,
really far off
and be misleading policymakers.
Hence the microdata.
Where my pitch is, if you're
going to do macro policy,
you have to have
micro data, period,
but that's partly a belief
that I've acquired over time.
It's a matter of experience.
Although, it's not always true.
The approximations
can be very helpful.
OK.
So the lecture today is
kind of the reverse of that.
Instead of putting structure
on indirect utility functions,
we're going to see if we can
get by with almost no structure
at all on preferences
and still be
able to make predictions which
are testable or rejectable.
So this part, this lecture is
all about economic science.
I featured the science of
experiments in Lecture 1
as a motivation for the class.
We went through [Koopmans]
and Lucas and Josh and Matzkin
and so on.
So this is very much the
science of doing experiments,
and I'll tell you
exactly what we're
going to do with
micro data, depending
on the amount of data
available, and also macro data,
trying to put as little
structure as possible
and still get
rejectable restrictions.
Said that.
So we're going to go through
consumer optimization again,
which is, as always,
a bit of a review.
We're going to
approach that as if we
had an infinite amount of
data, and that will take us
back to the Slutsky
matrix, which
you may have forgotten by now,
but I'll try to remind you.
That's with an infinite
amount of data,
we get restrictions that we can
reject consumer rationality,
in principle.
And then we'll do the same
thing with finite data
and still derive algorithms
running on finite data
sets that would allow us to
not reject or alternatively
reject the rationality of the
household generating the data.
Then, we'll come
back to Lucas a bit
in computational
considerations, which
I think has been clear
throughout the lectures
that we visit from time to time.
And I have dug up some really
interesting computer science
material to share with
you about how hard or easy
it is to solve certain problems
and whether it matters,
be provocative.
And then we'll go to
general equilibrium theory
and kind of do the same
thing all over again.
And that's going
to again come back
to this you need micro to do
macro statement that I just
mentioned.
OK.
To get in the content
of it, this slide
appears to come out of nowhere.
It was actually almost
part of the lecture
we had on income and
substitution effects,
and I'll remind you
of that in a minute.
In particular, it has to
do with the Hicksian demand
and the expenditure function.
Well, I'll remind you now.
We did utility maximization
subject to the budget,
and we got the Walrasian
or Marshallian demand.
We also decomposed that
into income and substitution
effects, and the way we got
the substitution effects
was to do compensation.
Prices, say if they
decrease, are associated
with increases in income.
We take the income
effects away, and just
look at how demands change,
as we change prices.
In other words, we
minimize the expenditure
necessary to achieve a
certain level of utility,
and we got the Hicksian demand.
So with the Hicksian demand
and the expenditure function,
we didn't actually go through
these properties in Lecture 3,
but they are intuitive.
If the utility
function is continuous
represents locally
non-satiated preferences.
We might as well
define the consumption
set to be the non-negative
L dimensional orthont.
Then, we have the
following four properties
the expenditure function, this
minimized expenditure at prices
p to achieve a certain
utility level u,
is homogeneous of degree what?
1 in those prices p.
I think I slipped up the
other day, when I said 0,
and then I switched back to 1.
It depends on what object.
When we do utility
maximization to budgets,
if we increase
income and prices,
things are homogeneous of degree
0, because nothing changes.
But this is a property of
the expenditure function.
So logically, if prices
go up, and you're
hitting the same
level of utility,
it's going to cost you more.
So the expenditure
is just double,
if your doubling prices.
It's homogeneous of degree 1.
The expenditure function
for any given price vector p
is increasing in utility.
That makes sense, when
you think about having
nice concave indifference
curves, or even
linear indifference curves.
If you do increase u by moving
further and further north out,
hitting higher and higher
indifference curves,
then to minimize the expenditure
of achieving those points,
the expenditure has to go up.
Likewise, as prices
go up, expenditures
go up, which I kind
of already said.
And this is a key property.
In addition, the
expenditure function
is concave in the prices.
So we're given that the
utility function represents
local non-satiated preferences.
We're not given much else.
So this might be
a bit surprising.
This allows for it to be linear,
however, and in a minute,
we'll make it strictly concave.
Anyway, you remember
how these proofs go.
Pick two prices, pick
a linear combination,
prove that an intermediate
combination is also minimizing
expenditure, et cetera.
And then the utility
expenditure function
is continuous in both objects,
but what I want to focus on
is number three,
that the expenditure
function is concave in
prices for fixed utility.
OK.
Relatedly, the
Hicksian demand is,
if you're going to achieve
a target utility u,
then you will achieve
it exactly, essentially.
That is to say, the x's,
which are part of the solution
to the minimizing
expenditure problem
when substituted into
the utility function,
generate u exactly.
if preferences are,
number two, convex,
then these minimized
Hicksian demands
are convex valued,
entertaining multiple solutions
that minimize expenditure,
for given p and u.
But if preferences
are strictly convex,
then this h function is
single-valued and continuous.
So here, it's where the strict
convexity of the preferences
comes in, which we're
going to get to again in 4.
3 says, this Hicksian
demand is single value
if it's single valued, which it
would be with strictly convex
preferences.
Then, it's differentiable,
and moreover,
when you take the
derivative of it,
with respect to say a price
p of L, for the Lth good,
you get the minimized--
you get the quantities back.
So the intuition for
this is expenditure
is just p1 x1 p2 x2
dot dot dot pL xL.
You take the
derivative with respect
to p, you're going to get the x.
That's a bit sloppy, and we did
the envelope theorem earlier
and reviewed it last time.
But basically, the derivative
at the optimizing minimized
expenditures, at the
parametric price, p sub L,
is you get the solution
back, the Hicksian demand.
So these two pieces, 3
and 3, on each of the two
slides generate this statement.
That if you take
the Hicksian demands
and differentiate with
respect to prices, then--
because level h is on
the right-hand side in 8,
but the derivative is already
on the left hand side.
So if you're differentiating
the right all over
again with respect to p,
we're double differentiating,
so to speak, the left-hand side.
So we get these second-order
partial derivatives,
[? own ?] end cross
of the expenditure function,
when we differentiate
the Hicksian demands.
This is really compact notation.
Obviously, there's
a whole vector
of prices, p1 through
pL, et cetera.
We're writing it down almost
as if it were single dimension,
but it's meant to capture
the entire L by L matrix.
That is to say, derivative
of the first Hicksian
demand with respect to the
first price, the first Hicksian
demand good with respect to
the second, price and so on,
going across the row.
Fill out all the rows.
So it has all the own II, HIPI
derivatives, as well as HIJ,
Ith good with respect
to the Jth price.
It's all loaded into
this compact notation.
Now, I'm saving the best for
last, which is this guy here
is the matrix of second-order
derivatives of the expenditure
function, and three
already told us
the expenditure
function is concave.
So that means, if you think
about first-order conditions
and second-order conditions,
that second-order conditions
are going to be satisfied
for a concave function.
And in fact, if you look it up--
stuff does slip memory a bit--
it means that this matrix of own
and cross-partial derivatives
is symmetric and
negative semidefinite.
You may not remember that.
You think about one
good, then you just
have first the ii derivative.
You think about two, then you're
going to have a 2 by 2 matrix.
Then, you have the
determinant of that matrix.
If you have three goods,
then it's a bit tricky.
To factor the matrix,
got to figure out
the determinant of each of
the subcomponents and so on.
But an equivalent
way to check and see
whether all the conditions are
satisfied for concavity is just
to pre-multiply
and post-multiply
the matrix by a prime and
a, as arbitrary vectors,
and make sure the
result is negative.
So that's a bit of a review.
Don't worry about it if
you never learned it.
It's the same thing as getting
concavity of the expenditure
function.
OK.
So what?
Well, it's a bit problematic.
I said the motive today
was to get restrictions
on observables, but
we don't see this guy.
We don't see the
Hicksian demand.
We just see the Marshallian
demand, so we're in trouble.
Except this-- this
is a statement
about the Slutsky matrix.
What we want to find,
which is the derivative
of that thing we just
looked at, turns out,
it is associated
with observables.
This is the Lth good changing
with respect to the Kth price
is equal to--
the way the whole demand is
changing of the Lth good,
as we change the price pk.
But we adjust for
the income effect,
which is how the Lth
grid is changing,
as we change income or
wealth, post multiplied
by the quantity of the good
price of which is changing,
namely pxk for pk.
OK?
So then, you're probably
still struggling.
I went back to check.
You may remember this.
Remember this lecture where we
did the income and substitution
effects, these guys?
And then we decomposed
the total demand change,
as a consequence
of the price change
into the substitution effect
and the income effect.
And we had to clarify that the
income effect was negative,
because in that diagram we
had p on the wrong axis, given
the strange way economists
invented demand curves.
So then, what we're
trying to do today
is to get this
substitution effect matrix,
and we're getting
it from observables,
how demand is changing as price
changes plus how demand is
changing as income is changing.
So this simple example
equation is elaborated
in this Slutsky matrix.
The sign changes,
only because we
changed what's on
the left-hand side,
from the total demand to
the substitution effect.
Substitute effect equals total
demand plus income changes.
Substitution effect
equals change
in total demand
plus income changes.
So in fact, the
Slutsky thing is really
familiar to you from
that entire lecture
that we did on income
and substitution effects.
And now back to the
point, to reiterate.
This thing under the assumptions
on the previous slide
has to be, if we enumerated
it out for all l and k,
a symmetric negative
semidefinite matrix.
So we can fill in
the I, the row column
elements from all
these observables,
and just check and
see whether it's true.
OK.
So I should have said,
this is with infinite data,
because we're talking about
having derivatives, which
is infinitesimally small data.
But it's still good to know
that, in principle, there's
a way to do it.
If you can't identify
something with infinite data,
you're not going to identify
something with finite data.
So let's review where we are.
The goal here is to see whether
we have testable restrictions.
In particular, ask the
question whether what we see,
in terms of the demand function,
came from a utility maximizing
rational consumer or not.
So I'm just going to stick
you with a big database,
in this case an infinite
dimensional database,
and have you check and see
whether it could have come
from a rational maximizing--
maximizing some utility
function, consumer.
OK?
So what are the three properties
homogeneity of degree 0.
Again, multiplying income
and prices by a scalar,
you just get--
nothing changes.
That's a statement about not
being naive about inflation,
for example.
Although, I guess arguably,
it could be violated,
but it seems pretty reasonable
for a thoughtful consumer.
In two different situations
with prices and income
just being multiples
of one another,
they shouldn't
change what they do.
The second property
is called Walras Law,
which is a fancy name for
spending all your money.
Namely, if you have
wealth w, and you add up
all the expenses
observed to take place
at prices p, that's also
equal to your wealth.
So you don't underspend.
You can't overspend, because
that would violate the budget.
You don't have the money.
But you could, in
principle, underspend.
However, a rational
consumer with
local non-satiated preferences
would never do that.
They go right out to the budget.
Technically, Walras Law
is used to mean you only
need to solve for
the equilibrium--
if there are capital
L goods, you only
need to solve for the
equilibrium in L minus 1
of them.
Because the Lth is pinned
down by this budget equation.
So it's like no
extra restrictions.
And finally, the Slutsky
matrix, if the demand function
is differentiable
and single-valued,
then that matrix, s sub p and
w, is symmetric and negative
semidefinite.
OK.
Who cares?
Here's the content.
If the other two
things are true--
which one would
argue is likely to be
true in any generated data set--
if you can find anything
that's not symmetric or not
negative semidefinite,
then preferences
could not have come
from a locally--
from locally non-satiated
preference, as a solution
to the max problem.
So this is the necessity part.
If we have utility max, then all
three properties have to hold.
Otherwise, can't be true that it
came from utility max problem.
Now, one thing-- we'll get
to convexity in a minute,
but I'll just earmark that,
that there is no statement here
about convexity, just locally
non-satiated preferences,
and it's not quite fair.
The Slutsky thing we
derived did rely on--
at least the way
I presented it, it
relied on convex preferences.
The question here
is whether one can
test for non-convex preferences
with the data, which
is a bit of a
different question,
and I'll come back to that.
So those three
properties not only
have to be true, if
we maximize utility,
but if they're true in the
data, then we can always
find a utility function that
generated the observations,
and that's called integrability.
Let me give you the
formal statement of it.
So this is like the
sufficient part.
If preferences of a household
are strictly increasing,
strictly quasiconcave, then
the Walrasian demand function
is homogeneous of degree
0, satisfies Walras Law,
and it's Slutsky matrix
is symmetric and negative
semidefinite.
That's the first part.
The second part is, if the
demand function is homogeneous
of degree 0, satisfies
Walras's Law,
and the Slutsky matrix
is symmetric and negative
semidefinite, then there
exists a utility function that
is increasing quasiconcave that
would generate the observed
data.
So let me backtrack.
This first part A is
what we did initially.
The second part B is the
integrability theorem.
It says we can work
backwards from the data set
to an underlying utility
function, which again has
to be increasing
quasiconcave and would
generate the data as if a
solution to the max problem.
So this is the bit about
not testability of convex
preferences, and the idea
is we've deliberately
drawn underlying utility
function, which is not concave
or these upper contour sets
are not strictly convex.
You see the wiggle here.
But if we start
rotating a budget
line or along the
indifference curve
and picking out
the tangencies, we
would generate the
Hicksian demand, et cetera.
Then, we get to this
particular budget line,
where we're no longer pivoting.
We jump.
For a moment, we would be
indifferent between this point
and this point, and as
we keep rotating the line
and making it have
less and less slope,
we will start finding pivoting
along this curve indifference
curve.
That shouldn't be bending
back up again, but anyway.
So the point is we never end
up in this non-concave portion.
So we don't generate
observables in there.
What we would infer is they
have strictly concave, or weakly
linear, preferences over
certain ranges of prices, which
is consistent with an underlying
weakly quasiconcave utility
function.
Now this doesn't mean that
we can't test for convexity
of preferences in other
ways, but this whole lecture
is about restrictions on data
that come from market behavior,
maximizing utility
subject to budgets.
And if that's all
we have in the data,
we cannot test for convexity.
Again, the statement, there
exists a utility function that
is increasing in quasiconcave.
That's probably
confusing, because it
looks like we just said,
the utility function
is quasiconcave.
No, this one is not.
That's the true
underlying function,
but we can't test for that.
All we see in the
observables are the one
that as if generated
the dashed line,
and that utility
function is quasiconcave.
So that's the content
of this statement.
It's as if there were a utility
function which is quasiconcave.
Questions?
All right.
So operationally, we might as
well assume convex preferences,
because we're not going to
be able to reject it anyway.
That's an odd-sounding corollary
to this whole first part
of the lecture, which is the
goal of placing restrictions
on data, whether data place
restrictions on theory or not.
And finally, let me
say again, why are we
trying so hard to see what
we could potentially reject?
The answer is, if
say it's not Slutsky,
then it could not have come from
a rational consumer maximizing
utility, and that's good news.
If for any data
set, we can always
find a consumer
maximizing utility
that could have
generated the data,
then there's no
content to the theory.
It might be fun
to do the theory,
but it's a vacuous
empirical exercise.
It has no content,
if it's always true.
Fortunately, it's
not always true,
and these are the
conditions we can check.
It's an odd thing,
because then you
could end up with, oh my god,
where did this data come from?
It couldn't be coming from a
rational consumer, but anyway.
We actually like it if we can
reject things, strange science.
So now, let's go to finite data.
We had observed,
a minute ago, we
had the entire Walrasian
demand function
for arbitrarily small changes
in prices and wealth and so on,
but typically, we
don't see that.
We don't have an
infinite data set.
We may have a household,
and if we're lucky
we can observe that household
over long periods of time
and see what decisions
are being made,
if those things are recorded
on Alipay, for example.
And if it were true that
everything that was bought
was acquired on Alipay,
then we would see--
and if we also saw the
wealth, because they're
spending everything
on Alipay, then we
would actually, potentially,
have a very long data set,
but not infinite.
So we want to see whether
we can, nevertheless,
test the hypothesis
of rationality,
and the answer is
going to be positive.
There is a way to take the
data and run an algorithm
and see whether the results
are consistent but potentially
inconsistent.
And in the latter
case, we can reject.
So this is the
definition of the Weak
Axiom of Revealed Preference.
Let's start with just
having two observations
with different prices
and different choices.
(p1, x1) (p2, x2) is
a pair of observations
on prices and
consumption bundles,
implicitly for a
given household.
pt doesn't mean,
necessarily, t over time,
although you could
imagine we observed
at t equal 1 the first
choice and a t equal 2
the second choice.
But that's confusing, because
it raises the dynamic issues
and everything else.
So t is really only meant
here to index the data point,
and there's two data points
and hence two values for t.
And let's suppose
it's not trivial,
so these choices are different.
And we say the individual
choices, these choices,
satisfy the weak axiom
of real preference,
if whenever at the second price
is p2 with x2 chosen and x1
in the interior of the
budget, we must then have,
at prices p1, spending (p1,
x1), that x2 is not attainable.
So let me say it again.
It's an if-then thing.
If this is true in the data
that, if they had chosen x1,
they would not have been
spending all their money--
if that configuration
is true in the data,
then we better find
that, at prices p1,
the valuation of expenditures on
x2 is strictly greater than x1,
and again, the idea is
revealed preference.
So at prices p2, they are
revealed to prefer x2 over x1,
because x1 is available,
and they didn't choose it.
So it better not be the
case that, in some other way
of looking at the data,
this inequality is violated.
Because if at prices
p1, x2 were available,
because it's interior to
the budget at prices p1,
then to be consistent,
they should have chosen it,
because it's already shown
to be weakly preferred to x1.
So that's the idea.
If this is true,
then this is true.
So it's like a statement
of an algorithm running
over the data, and we're
going to generalize that.
So what happens if
this isn't true?
This is true, but this is not.
So let's look at a picture.
At prices p2, they choose
x2, so on the budget.
And x1 is interior, so
that's this condition.
x1 is interior to the
budget at prices p2.
Then, we look at prices
p2, p1, are they?
Here.
So here's x1.
It's on the budget at price p1.
The question is, where is x2?
In this case, x2 is interior
to the p1 budget line.
That violates.
We didn't want to find that.
That violates what
ought to be true,
and so it violates
the weak axiom.
Not only that, try to
draw indifference curves
from a quasiconcave or
linear or strictly convex,
you can't do it.
You'd get a tangency here,
you'd get a tangency here,
or looking at the bottom,
the indifference curves
would cross.
There's no way you can draw
this picture without crossing
the indifference curves and have
a tangent at the two choices.
Well, we learned
right in Lecture 2
that indifference curves can
cross for rational consumers.
A is preferred to B.
B is preferred to C .
A is preferred to C. You
may remember that diagram.
So that's meant to be an
intuitive proof of the picture
of the proposition.
So in conclusion,
for the weak axiom
if the agent has
preferences which
are locally non-satiated
and rational,
then given observations
on prices, expenditures,
and wealth, you must have
that the pairs of data points
satisfy this Weak Axiom of
Revealed Preference, WARP.
OK?
So now, we want to generalize.
We have here still
two data points,
just slightly
different notation.
The data points are
indexed by t and s,
and we write that
the t data point of x
is revealed directly preferred
to the data point indexed by s,
if x is available at prices pt.
So again, at prices
pt, they chose xt.
That's the way the
data are organized.
They could have chosen xs,
because it's in the budget,
but they didn't do it.
So we say directly
reveal preferred.
This might imply
strict preference,
but it doesn't really mean that.
It just means, as with the
axioms of reveal preference,
what we see is what they want.
That's all we're saying.
They reveal to prefer it, then
they continue to prefer it.
In this case, they prefer it
over other things they could
have chosen and didn't.
It's pretty simple-minded.
Then, we come to I almost want
to say indirectly revealed
preferred.
Actually, it's in
parentheses here
to contrast with the
directly revealed preferred.
So now we're going to
have a bigger data set.
We're going to have
a whole sequence,
and we say that
xt R without the d
is just revealed preferred
not directly preferred.
Or if you like, I for
indirectly preferred,
xt is revealed
preferred to xs, if we
have a sequence of data
points, such that pairwise we
have direct revelation.
So we want xt to,
at the beginning,
to be compared to xs at the end.
But we do that, we never
see, say in the data,
that they're
directly comparable.
Instead, we see
xt in a situation
where, within the budget, xt
is revealed directly preferred
to xr1.
In another piece
of the data, we see
xr1 is revealed directly to
xr2, and so on down the chain,
with xrk being revealed
directly preferred to xs.
So this is like the
transitivity axiom,
which is part of the axioms
of rational consumer.
Right?
We have a chain in which we have
directly revealed preference.
Hence, the one at
the beginning ought
to be indirectly revealed
preferred to the one
at the end.
Next xt to xs.
So then we come to
the Generalized Axiom
of Revealed
Preference, called GARP
so I don't know there was
a famous movie "The World
According to Garp."
I don't know if you-- was
a Robin Williams movie.
They didn't mean this.
So generalized
revealed preference
is building on this notion of
indirectly revealed preference.
If we have the data points
of the dimensionality--
the data set is capital T,
and we have prices and demands
for each T, then the general
axiom of revealed preference
means that, if xt is
indirectly revealed to xs, then
if we're able to
make the comparison,
we have the strict inequality.
Namely, xt is preferred
to xs, it better
be the case that, at prices
ps, xt is outside the budget,
relative to the
expenditures on xs.
And the intuition, as I wrote in
red at the bottom of the slide,
is simply imagine this
inequality is reversed.
Then, we would have, at prices
ps, xt is within the budget,
and xs ought to be at least
weakly if not strictly
preferred, because xs was
chosen, and xt was available.
So xs would be directly
revealed to be preferred to xt,
according to this definition.
But it goes the other way
here, where xt is revealed,
granted indirectly,
to be preferred to xs.
So that if this were a strict
inequality going the other way,
we would intuitively violate.
These two pieces of
information would not
be consistent with each other.
Now, again, you should think
about this as an algorithm.
Some classes do this.
I found one on the web today.
They give students
a very large data
set of prices and
quantities and just
ask them is this consistent
with a rational household?
And how do you approach that?
Well, you start looking
for these chains.
You have to construct them
algorithmically and get,
as a result when it's true,
a statement about x and t
indirectly reveal preferred.
And then in the
same data set, go
looking for an instance where
there was a direct comparison,
and it better be that
the inequality is weakly
going this direction.
So it's an algorithm,
I'm trying to say.
Because again, if it doesn't
go in this direction,
then it contradicts the whole
notion of revealed preference
and transitivity.
So again, good news, ironically.
We are potentially
able to reject.
There are comparisons
in the data which,
if this inequality
goes the other way,
would tell us there's no
way that this data came
from a rational
maximizing consumer,
and that's good for us.
Now, it doesn't mean that,
in any given data set,
you will necessarily
find a violation,
but you end up with
a weak statement
that the data set look as if
there was nothing inconsistent
in this data, with respect
to the statement that they
came from a rational
maximizing consumer.
So we should check and
make sure that that's true,
and that's the spirit of it.
Questions?
OK.
So let me get to the
computational part.
These guys at Caltech,
consumer theory
assumes consumers possess
infinite computational
abilities.
Like they can solve max problems
and potentially hard problems.
Proponents of
bounded rationality
want to require that any
reasonable model of consumer
behavior incorporate
computational constraints.
In other words, they may not be
able to solve a hard problem.
They may choose
something, but it
wouldn't be the full
solution, because they're not
able to compute it.
And Echenique and his coauthors
are saying, that's false.
Very much in the spirit
of revealed preference,
any consumption data
set that is compatible
with a rational consumer--
excuse me-- is also
compatible with
a rational and computationally
bounded consumer.
That is to say, the
data set in hand
can always be rationalized
by a utility function that's
pretty easy to solve, meaning
solved in polynomial time.
So this is very
much like not being
able to test the
convexity of preferences.
You start with
something non-convex,
but it generates a data
set that could also be
generated by something convex.
We start with
something that could
have come from the household
solving a hard problem,
but it could also have come from
a household solving a simpler
problem.
I'm not giving you any
intuition on this right now.
I'm telling you what
these computer scientists
have figured out.
And again their metric
is, how hard is it
to solve the problem?
Looking at
derivatives and so on,
how long does it
take, as we, say,
increase the number of goods?
If it's exponential, it's bad.
If it's polynomial, it's good.
All right.
Another version of this, instead
of having a single household
maximizing, or otherwise,
we have multiple agents
interacting in a market economy.
We want to say, if possible,
that the observed market
outcomes are consistent not only
with individual maximization
but with Walrasian equilibrium.
So what is the
empirical content?
Is it really hard to solve
the general equilibrium
computationally?
In which case, it's
not likely we're
going to be able to
accept in the data
that it came from the
underlying economy,
or it's a version of the
individual maximization
problem.
That there's another economy,
which is actually easier
to solve, that could have
generated the same data.
This is totally
remarkable stuff.
Because it goes
against the grain
of the way one would like to
think about it, as rational
as consumers can
possibly be, it's
unlikely they can solve in
their minds problems that
prove intractable for
computer scientists equipped
with the latest technology.
It's a cool statement.
These are really famous
theorists, by the way.
Gilboa, Schmaidler,
and Postlewaite
solve in their minds--
get it-- what you would
need for a supercomputer.
If an equilibrium is not
efficiently computed--
this is the market version--
much of the credibility of
using the predicate that we have
rational agents is lost, and
a shorthand version of that--
if your laptop can't find
it, neither can the market.
But these guys are
saying, that's just wrong.
It's just completely wrong.
Because they misunderstand
the role of models
in economics, which is as if
the model were a reality, then
there are restrictions on data.
It is not a statement
that we have
all of the reality
captured in the model.
So the reality behaves as
if the theory were true.
A consumption data set is either
not rationalizable at all--
so that's the rejection part.
They're not going
to overturn that.
There's still content.
It's either not
rationalizable at all,
or it's rationalizable by
utility function that's
fairly easy to maximize.
When I show you these slides,
I want to show you more,
but I guess we
have limited time.
So I probably should have put
this paper on the reading list
as optional.
OK.
So let's go to general
equilibrium in a paper of Brown
and Matzkin, which
all things considered,
is relatively recent.
Suppose we're given data set
on a number of households,
capital I in the
economy, and we see
their individual endowments--
private ownership economy, omega
I, across households capital I.
Then, there's something that
I'll elaborate in words now
called Anything Goes.
General equilibrium theory does
not put restrictions on data.
Anything goes.
And that was a killer.
That killed the whole
subject for a long time,
because of what I'm saying.
Now, the object in question
was our famous excess demand
function that we have used
before, the aggregate demand
function that
we've been focusing
on with aggregation and so on.
What shape does that
aggregate demand function
have, as we vary prices?
And the answer was whatever
wiggle and turn it has,
including upsloping
portions and so on.
You can always find
an underlying economy
that would have generated
that excess demand.
So this part of it is the
seeming answer to the question.
What happens if we don't
put any restrictions
on utility functions, other
than things like rationality?
And the answer is
anything could happen.
That aggregate
demand function could
look any way you want it to.
For any aggregate
demand function,
we can populate an economy with
a finite number of households,
give them certain preferences
and ownership of resources
in such a way that we can
get that aggregate demand
to shift and turn and
do whatever we want.
So again, the shorthand
is anything goes,
and because we could
never reject the model,
people thought that general
equilibrium had no content,
and they stopped doing it.
It was discredited.
This was not just one person.
It was Hugo Sonnenschein,
Debreu, and Mantel.
OK.
But let's just change this.
First, what is this seemingly
reasonable but actually crazy
thing that we actually
see the excess demand?
We never see that.
If we see market
economy, we only
see market clearing prices.
We don't see what happens
out of equilibrium.
So we only see where it crosses.
We see the fixed points.
Well, let's give us a
little more data then.
Given a set of
observations on prices
and individual endowments,
does there exist--
OK.
So T now indicates the economy.
It's as if we're going to
go in the cross section,
across several or
many economies that
vary in the individual
ownership of endowments.
So it's omega IT for the
Tth economy observation.
For any T that varies
over I, we have
a finite number of households,
but T is varying in the sample.
That's the number of
economies in the sample.
Those economies are all
alike for preferences,
that's assumed.
But they differ in the ownership
structure, the omega ITs.
So then does there
exist a sequence
of these economies, each with
its associated aggregate excess
demand, but such that
those prices that we see
stuck into the aggregated
excess demand equals 0.
This last statement
is just a statement
that the price has
come from a market.
In other words, the data
set we're going to see
would be the prices that
because it's a market
or associated with zero excess
demand, equilibrium prices.
So we're going to see
equilibrium prices,
and we're also going to
see individual endowments,
assuming preferences
are all the same.
So I'll give you the punch line.
That's Brown and Matzkin.
The punch line is going to
be what we've been saying
throughout the lecture today.
Namely, if we're
given data like this,
we can actually reject
that the data could have
come as a market equilibrium.
That is to say, that
the market the data
couldn't potentially never have
come from individual household
maximization and
market clearing.
So it has content.
Here's the differentiable
version of it.
As abstract as general
equilibrium theory is, this
Sonnenschein, Debreu,
and Mantel is overturned.
They're applying it to
an exchange economy,
where we see prices
and endowments.
They derive necessary
and sufficient conditions
for the equilibrium prices as a
function of initial endowments,
and in their language,
they show that the economy
can be generically identified.
What they mean by that is there
is an underlying economy that
would have generated
the data, but also
that, in principle,
one could have not
been able to find
such an economy.
And then to summarize
where we are,
if you only had aggregate
data, you're sunk.
You're never going
to get conditions
that allow you to reject.
But when you have
individual data,
you can get testable
restrictions
and bring back the content of
general equilibrium theory.
So again, this summarizes
my deliberately provocative
statement that you need
micro data to do macro.
And then they go on to
talk about something
you're familiar with, because
we did it in the class.
We're sharing in
Indian villages.
It's not uncommon to
observe endowments,
like crops and prices.
We did a little bit
of that, less so
with the risk
sharing, in which case
their content works directly.
If you really believed you
were going from one village
to another, each
were self-contained.
They had the same
preferences and the premise
would be we're seeing
market outcomes,
then their theory
applies directly.
You can even go to large
economies, not villages,
and think about
types of individuals,
finite number of types, but
a large number of individuals
of a given type and again
you can use their artillery.
Now, interestingly,
lest you think
economists have this
all figured out,
an interesting question is how
to extend this to production.
They refer to changes
in fact or endowments,
which have observable
impact on factor prices.
So that's an allusion to
the trade lectures we did.
And they haven't
figured it out yet.
They haven't figured
out whether there
are rejectable restrictions.
Remember, when we did the
model, the 2 by 2 case,
we had constant returns to scale
and a few other assumptions.
So they're saying like
drop all assumptions.
Could we put
restrictions on data
and say we'd never see
violations of some kind,
and they haven't figured it out.
So we're on the research
frontier at this point.
So that's what I have
for today, again, very
much part and parcel of the
whole spirit of the class.
Which is to think
about economists
as running experiments, and
you saw three of them today.